Tibet known as the roof of the world
it's also been disputed for decades
china says it controls the region but
many Tibetans say they want it to be an
independent nation in 1949 communists
took over mainland China and less than a
year later the army occupied Tibet the
Dalai Lama remained the spiritual leader
of Tibet while China maintained ultimate
power over the region in 1959 after
years of resistance 30,000 Tibetans
revolted in the capital Lhasa they
suspected a government plot to kill the
Dalai Lama full-scale fighting broke out
and the spiritual leader escaped to
India thousands of Tibetans were killed
during the uprising China continues to
crackdown on the independence movement
Tibetans have protested in many ways
including setting themselves on fire the
Dalai Lama lives in exile in India along
with thousands of his followers and he's
changed his mind on independence seeking
a middle way he says he wants to bet to
be a truly autonomous region since the
Communist Party came to power in 1949
China has been cracking down on the
wiggers a Muslim ethnic minority so
what's at stake besides China's national
unity resources